pour jean-claude habiter ici c'est un
peu comme être à la maison c'est le crès
apple métier il fait partie des 24 au
locataire de cette maison construite en
à l'initiative de l'association bien
vieillir en val de jouer d'élus locaux
10 salariés s'occupent quotidiennement
de ces seniors une présence permanente
qui rassure marcelline vient de souffler
ses 100 bougies en toute quiétude
on est bien choyé les gens sont sympas
lolo au moins je me trompe but puis je
suis bien content comme les enfants
chantant chaque curé de trois millions
d'euros ont été nécessaires pour ce
projet de résidence expérimental la
première de ce type dans le département
elle mis sur l'accompagnement
personnalisé et la proximité entre
soignants et seigneur nous c'est sûr
vraiment la qualité de la prise en
charge ou on veut vraiment travailler
là-dessus où on met le paquet là-dessus
le moment du repas que si un moment très
important puisque pour une personne âgée
manger ça reste un réel plaisir donc il
faut que le repas soit de qualité donc
on travaille énormément là dessus des
repas cuisinés sur place et à base de
produits locaux
certains proviennent de la ferme à
quelques pas de la résidence
pour le maire de la commune cette
structure est aussi une réponse à l'
isolement dans le milieu rural autour de
saint bonnet de joux les ehpad et
hôpitaux était déjà complètement plein
on avait plus de place pour nos
personnes âgées du milieu rural et la
volonté municipale était vraiment de
pouvoir permettre aux personnes âgées de
rester sur leur lieu de vie la structure
répond aux demandes d'admission en
fonction des places disponibles
certaines sont mises sur liste d'attenté
les premiers prix s'élève à 1700 euros
par mois environ toutes charges
comprises